[Musique]
jean luc lemoine vous êtes prêt tout à
fait amélie vous restez avec nous vous
faites les captures avec nous ses
partisans le club breton dit bonsoir
bonsoir quand allez-vous allées pour
regarder 4 je vais surtout partir très
loin mais oui moi je me régale à une
question
oui d'autant qu'à faire les missions qui
vont en prendre plein la gueule mais pas
du tout pas du tout non non je vous
épargne parce que je trouve briand vous
pouvez me refaire les lunettes juste
pour le plaisir
oh je me régale même s'il est une
question bonjour je m'appelle maya je
voulais savoir comment vous sélectionnez
vos invités dans l'émission est ce que
c'est les plus intéressants qui viennent
ou juste ceux qui ont un peu de temps
libre
concept enregistré on savait pas que
c'était vous l'avez vu ce soir aucun
rapport et de vendre à jarry par exemple
je suis répond à ces questions c'est une
excellente question que vous posez la
charge maya la réponse est très simple
en fait nous recevrons juste les
meilleurs invités n'ont pas les plus
disponibles
alors c'est vrai que nous recevons
souvent les amis de matthieu delormeau
un temps on n'a pas le choix puisqu'il
est intime et que toutes les stars la
semaine dernière d'ailleurs nous
recevions un de ses poteaux
un de ses frères jérôme commandeur à un
magnifique complicité
tu es ma [ __ ] géante des joueurs
numérotés jamais je trouve que
[Musique]
je pense qu'il va s'en apercevoir
[Rires]
réponse de jérôme commandeur épaules ce
qu'ils savaient pas j'ai pas encore reçu
son chèque se fatigue même pas firma
fera sur roulettes et ouvre ainsi les
invités viennent aussi c'est bien
évident pour cyril qui est ce qu'on
appelle un influenceur un leader
d'opinion
un gourou 1 m une icône un avis dieu la
preuve c'est vous le savez peut-être
c'est un des français les plus suivies
sur twitter
même s'il faut dire la vérité il reste
moins de le numéro un c'est david
liétaert et david guetta
ouais mais comme il n'aime pas les
places d'honneur cyril a décidé d'agir
est lui aussi selon dans le remix pour
devenir number one tiens toi bien david
matin
ce qui ce passe connais pas des choses
[Musique]
tu m'as kctu m'agacer oui les cons on
t'appelle grosse [ __ ] d'un gros
l'humour est pas qu une affaire de paris
combo passons vite sur rémy alors
parfois sur le plateau on fait aussi de
belles rencontres
c'est un battant il ya quelques semaines
nous recevions texte vous vous rappelez
la venue de ce texte
et c'est cyril avait eu de quoi vit avec
son passé qui s'auto makes alors ce
texte est venu et sirène avait eu des
mots très aimable surtaxe des
compliments validé par presque tous les
chroniqueurs souffle un prime mais en
prime sur france 2 jeu mais voilà je
mets ici
ouais mais mes attributs que ça fait un
carton d'audience
je le dis moi je suis prêt à faire un
truc qui me semblent être des envies
[Applaudissements]
vous remarquerez que thierry ait eu un
doute car le vrai coup de foudre de la
soirée il s'est passé entre l'animateur
des z'amours et jean michel maire alors
je sais pas ce qu'ils ont dit homme qui
rit à moitié dans son lit merci oui je
pense que jean michel et ex vont faire
chambre à part il ya 6 gobelets foule
devinez pourquoi ça a un rapport avec
alien el kadiri mme way
excuse moi tu es ta famille 10 heures
hier donc à regarder mais il ya 6
gobelets s'il te plaît c'est
l'équivalent normalement de sic en hiver
le sig au blé river
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
une blague et où tu nous l'a fait jean
renel albert de monaco
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
sa matière bref bien à l'école c'était
le synthétique
[Applaudissements]
mais comme tu sais lire l'écossais merci
tu écoutes ça dans tous et à demain
c'est la saint valentin c'est la journée
des amoureux et c'est la seule chose qui
peut sauver le monde les amis je me
déplace uniquement avec ses danses
pierre-yves nous a fait beaucoup rire
taxis et des bus oui annoncé benjamin
castaldi qui est en face qui me faisait
beaucoup rire parce que l' avantage
d'être ici c'est que l'invité vous vois
pas de combien de réaction comme on veut
c'est très belle analyse
moi ce qui m'a fait le plus rire je
voudrais qu'on voit juste premier
magnéto
c'est l'athlète de matthieu delormeau
sur la vanne des gobelets regard de la
cfl ardennes de matthieu delormeau
c'est un pourri parce que ma femme était
à l'épaule regardez la regarder plus
enfin on va essayer de la garder
quelqu'un vienne à cayenne
excuse moi peut-être la famille disait
rien donné a regardé mais y'a 6 gobelets
s'il te plaît c'est l'équivalent
normalement deux sinon hui vers le sig
au blé river ah ouais
[Applaudissements]
je
une bonne émission c'est pas que des
bons réalité c'est aussi un bon public
et ici on a un public magnifique
et tellement facile à flatter non c'est
un public magnifique et surtout c'est un
public qui connaît bien tout le monde
[Applaudissements]
tu es là
alors y'a pas que le public mais bien
des missions il ya aussi les
chroniqueurs regardez c'est bon c'est
bon gros dit elle au vendredi tu
voudrais que des permis c'est comme
voldemort dans harry potter et ont fait
excuser capucine car écrit il ya il ya
peu de temps en septembre contre un bon
pied aux piliers de l'équipe
je sais pas si vous avez vu la semaine
dernière mais j'ai montré n'aura en
train de dessiner des zizis m avait dit
qu'elle avait honte qu'ils s'en rendent
même plus compte
alors je vais te rassurer nos j'ai
cherché j'ai vérifié
tu fais pas que ça pendant les pubs
[Applaudissements]
winnie mes courses de camions doit être
prête à l'église
bien tout va bien c'est joli non tu vas
n'était pas dans ma chambre
un des couples phares de l'équipe aussi
c'est évidemment isabelle et gilles
raoux ils veulent revenir ensemble je
pense eu sur ce très beau truc pourriez
isabelle ou pas voici mes peintures
manque tellement à vous vous en fichez
mais elle a évoqué le vrai problème
parce que gilles c'est un homme entier
qui s'explique fort très fort faut
savoir qu isabelle perdu 5 points
d'audition depuis ses débuts dans
l'émission
alors parfois il le vit bien et parfois
elle est au bout du rouleau comme la
semaine dernière au bord du précipice
tf1 pis les talents des autres c'est
quand même un monde
c'était la première chaîne française
européen mais ici c'est d'un quoi il
centre à baisser de près
ils sont même pas capables de former des
gens ils essayent le piller les autres
pour l'amour un télévisuelle j'espère
qu'elle n'ira pas mais comme elle a de
la morale elle ne parlait pratiquement
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
il avale non ils adorent ça va chauffer
rythme mais j'aime bien jouer du coup
jean louis paris la cote avec les mof
il aime bien au style de mec non ça le
fait non pas du tout c'est oui mais veut
pas dire ici j'ai compris mes bons fait
j'ai dans le livre h 48 poney alors j'y
vais je vais rester sur lui parce qu'il
a souvent été attaqué sur son physique
par matthieu delormeau un rat ça c'était
jusqu'à ce que gilles voix mathieu en
short le moment tendre de la semaine
c'est super bizarre tu as des mois les
deux c'est vraiment église 10 sport
comme ça
[Musique]
pourtant le vrai visage oui c'est vrai
visage de gilles je te défonce tout ça
voilà on le voit dans l'émission cache
pas grand chose il ya pas de même le
discours en battue c'est vrai que là
c'est bon faut justement il est attendu
pour demain ça peut on vraiment se
battre imminent j'ai mal à l'épaule j'ai
une tendinite est un machin soit y aller
il a un truc et je suis rétabli je te
défonce et sociales honte et alors là
matthews est prêt pour demain
ouais ya main qui sera le meilleur
animateur benjamin castaldi contre
mathieu de lambeaux jamais serré la main
avant lundi prochain
bref j'en ai deux je serai en arbitre
une chance sur nos benjamins soit pas là
maintenant il est là il se branche vient
tous pourvus il est comme un fou il
serait pas vous verrez vous irez
plusieurs des preuves on sera tous laval
en couille j'animerai cette émission est
le grand gagnant
je vous dirai ce qu'il aura demain et
vous allez être très très très content
alors là on parlait beauté et je suis
obligé je voudrais on le fait assez
rarement dans l'émission mais je
voudrais rendre hommage à l'équipe
maquillage et coiffure de l'émission est
vrai ne rend chaque jour beaucoup plus
beau que nous sommes en vrai mais et ils
ont du mérite
un exemple soraya une de nos coiffeuse
vous allez voir les difficultés qu'elle
a à faire un raccord à jean-michel
pendant la pub faut être patient et
surtout pas très susceptible
suivez
c'est tout
[Applaudissements]
mariage tête je sais que je les brosse
elle est magnifique
est ce que voulait une autre question
aujourd'hui quand ils hurlent au dessus
du lot c'est du grand 4/3 on y va de l
on y va bonjour je m'appelle denise
comme vous n'arrêtez pas de décliner
votre mission je voulais savoir est ce
que vous comptez bientôt faire une série
télévisée genre amour gloire et baba
c'est une excellente question chère
denise et oui c'est bien en projet c'est
un scoop
ah ouais ça sera un soap opéra où on
verrait les amours contrariées du magnat
de l'audiovisuel baba mac hanouna
volcanique compagnon matthew freud
lambeaux belle série a commencé il ya
longtemps mais il ya quinze jours un
formidable rebondissements à relancer
intrigue avec l'arrivée d'une jeune
intrigante agatha ou prou bon je veux
bien entendu parler du camji gate 1
le concert de kenji sombre histoire
fausse qu'il devait se rendre au concert
avec agathe jusqu'à ce que mathieu la
prenne
[Musique]
kenji
kenji demain toi
paris n'a pas eu de place
[Musique]
alors qu'il était très très énervé ça
aurait pu s'arrêter là mais non c'était
le cataclysme derrière parce que mathieu
faut pas le chercher donc très vite il a
trouvé les mots pour calmer les ardeurs
d'agathe vous allez voir en tout gentil
la cellule et surtout que les politiques
us récemment
je vous ai répondu je ne sais quoi
kelly
[Musique]
car ça
sa casa lien
alors comme ça parce que je déteste
quand j'ai fait jouer le réseau comment
que je joue et je tiens à dire j'ai
passé aucun réseau sfr oui vous savez
très bien ça fait longtemps que tu es
dans un tunnel la répulsion agathe je ne
l'ait pas fait oui oui alors en tout cas
vous avez vu pour la première fois
mathieu a trouvé quelqu'un qui me
donnait plus que lui dans l'émission
trop explorer et salons du fou de se
dire que bientôt peut-être il ne serait
plus la première dame
quand le doute sas ça s'installe dans le
regard de quelqu'un qui ne doute jamais
heureusement son amie valérie venu le
réconforter
[Musique]
j'ai parlé un peu avec la fibre loges
emmerder mais c'est l'autre sa colère et
séducteur ça marche bien chez moi on se
regarde
[Musique]
bien sûr tu continues là dessus
aujourd'hui évidemment pastoralia tools
de dénouer la relaxe en fait tout ça en
fait c'était une blague organisé par ce
qui est légal contraire ça parce que les
manigances tous les deux et je me suis
demandé comment il avait réussi à faire
marcher autant mathieu pourquoi il est
rentré dans le jeu
et bien c'est juste parce que je n'ai
pas toutes les infos j'adore c'est un
scoop tout à l'heure ouais ouais
l'az et messieurs le scoop de l'année
après ça vous ne regardez plus les
missions de la même façon regardez
je
médias
alors bougez vous
[Musique]
x
allez voir
c'est pareil dans l'émission avec
cyrille ternon
oui
regardez
collet
[Musique]
cette émission et rodrigues et
maintenant la question
voilà j'ai une angine
la norme comme avait eu du mal à
accepter
[Musique]
alors là là là attendu la la il aller
loin mathieu non la boule à laval -
franchement son nom c'est drôle mais
respectée quand même maintenant mais
respectée quand même nom mais jamais je
ne vois pas ce que j'ai des choses qu'on
n'aurait pas dû dire sur nous mais c'est
tellement énervée à mathieu là on arrête
de jouer 90 et sabha c'est très macho et
non là c'est là c'est grave là quand
même là franchement on pouvait pas dire
des choses comme ça et quoi il ya des
enfants qui pleurent à la maison non
mais mathieu comment vous pouvez dire en
plus c'est mon ami rim'k on pourrait
raconter des conneries pareilles c'est
pour ça qu'il m'appelait plus depuis un
certain temps nada mathieu figurez-vous
cambrai entre elles étaient très heureux
pour nous oui mais non mais oui vous
pouvez regarder la caméra s'il vous
plaît non parce que là c'est grave et
dire la vérité on la femme et les
enfants de cyril au moins mais dépêchez
vous qu'est-ce que je dise m'a dit la
vérité je peux pas la dire la vérité ça
suffit alors la vérité oui alors alors
alors nom est facile tu as fait je suis
un gros mytho
[Rires]
parce que là non la vision de loin quand
même mathieu à se retrouver
vous aller un peu loin non vraiment toi
une semelle de l'érotomanie non mr
souhaite que alors peut alors peut-être
que ça dans ma tête je suis on a eu des
moments j'ai pour moi on avait eu ce
qu'on appelle des moments en anglais non
mais vous allez moment où il n'y a pas
forcément de bisous et tout mais quelque
chose toi quoi ça rime avec l'unique
intérêt son nom mais mathieu sur l'école
parce que j'ai l'impression
il faut qu'on en parle ça fait un peu de
peine non mais non mais c'est un peu de
punch que je vous aime beaucoup mais la
somme que vous y croyez
et puis tu mérite une vraie histoire
vous avez mal et me le discours ce jeu
les malheureux suva il ya un thème
peut-être qu'un réparateur là aussi le
cas quand même le gars est amoureux
voilà oui mais bon mais malheureusement
oui mais pour être ont coupé soit à 2
ouais tu mérites du match aller elle est
en tout cas ça fait une très bonne
transition m alors vous vous expliquera
faut respecter quand même les non mais
c'est vrai je suis en couple quand même
je suis patient mais là il pense en fait
que je suis passion et la donne
oui il y aura une sanction chef sait qui
c'est que j'adore
voilà c'est ça c'est ça on aime tout
jamais serré et avions tous qu'il faut
que je sois plus dur avec des gérer non
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
c'est ça ça allait mais ce que c'est oui
je fais plein de compliments et tous les
métros de complément à prendre l'eau je
lui fais en recto lui le point au verso
et 21 petits bisous abbaoui non sans mal
excité c'est dommage
non mais non mais parce qu'après il va
encore se faire des filles manon mais
bon ça voilà mr cdh un jeu que je dis
oui je sais pas si je me fais des films
ou pas si si celui des deux qui a les
yeux qui brillent la ces qui tient à
billes me regarde toi oh non j'ai un peu
de fièvre mais sur ma liste et j'ai
toujours voulu commenter les spectateurs
puisque je vous dis tout jeu triste ça
je suis vraiment mal parce que le gars
commencent à me faire un peu de peine
parce que je crois qu'il ya un vrai
problème
est ce qu'on fait on enchaîne on fait
quoi si grand moment de télé c'est la
nouvelle transition que je pouvais
espérer pour aborder tout ce qu'on
n'aurait pas voulu voir et entendre les
missions allez on commence par un retour
soit passé de notre stagiaire théo dans
l'émission ah oui pour découvrez et qui
n'ont révélé qu'il était en stage dans
la société depuis un an et demi
tu vas devoir valider des gains pour
devenir le stagiaire le plus riche de
france
[Rires]
'le potentiel
est-ce que meriem pourrait que votre
fils enfin ça reste mon stylo comme si
vous étiez venu dans sa demie dont on
attendait yacine dibi qui est la
candidate du parti du brésil
cette ancienne strip millions
résidentiel de 2017
ap
combien yat-il dos dans le corps humain
combien yat-il dos
[Musique]
on a une petite machine contestera tout
à l'heure vous salissez la machine à
coups de poing et on verra qui va gagner
entre mathieu et olivier j'ai hâte de
voir ça sa moitié vous allez reprendre
là je suis une quiche à sa voix le mapaq
à ça on vous saurez faire un usage de
vos parapluies
oui les parapluies je veux bien des
parapluies un putsch a rappelé qu'on met
sur les desserts oh oui on les plante
dans les boules de gaz
[Musique]
non
des membres
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
j'y vais